bueno en principio juan yo diría que sí
que es un discurso pragmático para de
alguna manera apaciguar los ánimos en
las cancillerías occidentales tanto en
estados unidos pero también en buena
parte de europa de aquellos países que
participaron de la coalición de fuerzas
que ocupo afganistán 20 años pero hay
que recordar que lo que hoy se nos dice
fueron avances para la mujer afgana sólo
ocurrieron para una elite y sobre todo
en la capital en kabul y en algunas
capitales de provincia pero no así para
las mujeres afganas en los medios o en
el sector rural
qué tanto puede ser la diferencia
precisamente entre la situación a la que
se enfrentan las mujeres en afganistán
en ciudades como kabul respecto a lo que
se ve en esas zonas rurales de la si
usted ya hablaba bueno yo creo que
realmente la vida de cualquier mujer no
sólo en afganistán depende mucho del
lugar geográfico del lugar donde habite
si es en el medio rural nada tiene que
ver con las zonas urbanas eso ocurre
también en toda la américa latina por
ejemplo o en buena parte de áfrica o de
asia-pacífico en el caso de las mujeres
de afganistán yo creo que es un país que
viene siendo invadido sucesivas veces
que hay guerra de guerrillas y yo creo
que la condición de la mujer afgana ya
era muy dura de por sí antes de la
llegada de las tropas comandadas por
eeuu pero evidentemente lo que allí ha
pesado son años de pobreza de
desigualdades económicas y sobre todo
los códigos tribales que todavía el
lastran la emancipación de una mujer
afgana que en la década del 60 y en las
capitales únicamente si logró poder
avanzar en cuanto al derecho
de libre movimiento en la capital o por
ejemplo asistir a la escuela pública o
poder tener educación terciaria es decir
acudir a las universidades y poder
defender su puesto de trabajo si eran
doctoras médicos pero también por
ejemplo abogadas e incluso maestras
también yo creo que es muy diferentes y
en lo que les espera a las mujeres en el
medio rural dependerá mucho de los
señores de la guerra que todavía
continuarán apostando justamente a
pelear por el poder y disputarle el
poder central en kabul a los talibán
juan y pensando las mujeres que
consiguen salir del país como puede ser
la adaptación de aquellos que abandonen
afganistán y empiecen una vida en
occidente bueno eso va a depender mucho
de los planes de reasentamiento de estas
familias de afganos habrá que ver si son
mujeres que salen solas o acompañadas
por un esposo por un padre o quizás con
hijos menores a su cargo el shock
cultural va a ser inevitable pero yo
creo que muchas de ellas estarán
deseosos de poder beneficiarse también
de las libertades individuales de las
que gozan otras mujeres por ejemplo en
europa
eeuu pero ciertamente yo creo que tiene
que haber planes que contemplen una
integración de estas mujeres que sea
paula tiene que sea escalonada no se les
puede pedir y exigir que sea una
integración y una cohesión de sociedad
inmediata porque les va a llevar un
tiempo adaptarse a esas nuevas
libertades pero además poder negociarlo
con sus familias recordemos que los
derechos de los que el islám ofrece o
dispone para la mujer no solo a ghana
sino cualquier mujer musulmana muchas
veces se han visto cercenados por
interpretaciones que tienen que ver por
los sustratos culturales con los usos y
costumbres de cada país en este caso de
afganistán un país que evidentemente
tiene otras pautas culturales diferentes
por ejemplo a mujeres musulmanas de
marruecos con lo cual dependerá mucho de
los planes de la educación a la que
puedan acceder proyectos de cohesión
social de integración social ya sea en
españa' ya sea en alemania o en aquellos
países que ahora se aprontan para
recibir a los órganos
sí y como cree usted que será la lucha
de las mujeres afganas dentro y fuera de
afganistán para intentar preservar esos
derechos esos pocos avances adquiridos
en las dos últimas décadas
bueno eso va a depender si realmente
acompaña las familias de estas mujeres
que ya se han manifestado nada más
conocer que regresaban los talibán al
poder aunque hay que recordar que todo
esto está muy tergiversado por los
medios de comunicación porque nos llegan
es realmente con cuentagotas las
informaciones pero sobre todo porque la
comunidad internacional ha sido omisa
durante 20 años a la tarea de exigir
responsabilidades a aquellos que
supuestamente intervenían en afganistán
no sólo para perseguir al talibán sino
para sentar las bases de un estado
democrático afganistán hoy como ayer
sigue siendo un tablero de ajedrez donde
las potencias regionales y
extrarregionales pután esa partida igual
que hicieron durante la etapa de guerra
fría estados unidos y la unión soviética
muchísimas